tu es content dans la vie en général oui
tu t'entends bien avec tes copains oui
il y a jamais de bagarre à l'école oh
moi
si raconte-moi ça oh
il y a Laur qui me grriffe avec des
yaourts il te griffe avec des yaourts
quelle basse mentalité Laurent il
s'appelle mais pourquoi il te griffe
avec des yaourts par-ce que j'étais
méchant oh et qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que tu avais fait pour être méchant bah
c'était pas vrai ah oui mais qu'est-ce
qui était pas vrai que j'étais méchant À
quoi tu joues à l'école bah je dessine
non mais dans la cour de récréation à
quoi vous jouez avec les copains bah on
joue et ben on fait des pleuses les quoi
des pleuses des pleuses bah vous savez
ce que c'est que les pleuses